my first is canada's birthday the annual
event is usually celebrated with family
barbecues
and fireworks like these
however with fresh revelations about the
country's history of abuse towards its
native population
this year many canadians are pushing for
the party to be cancelled
this was a crime against humanity
an assault on a first on first nation
people we are proud people
the only crime we ever committed as
children was being born
indigenous just weeks ago it was
announced that a mass grave was found
with the remains of 215 native children
in kamloops british columbia
which used to be the largest residential
school in canada
more recently another 751 unmarked
graves were discovered
at a cemetery near another residential
school in the province of saskatchewan
some believe that up to 6 000 indigenous
children died at the schools
most often due to disease abuse and
neglect the government endorsed and
funded the 130 residential schools which
once stood across the nation they were
operated primarily by the catholic
anglican and protestant churches
from the 1800s on 150 000 first nations
children passed through the system
which was built to assimilate native
children into canadian society
forcing them to convert to christianity
while not allowing them to speak
their native languages the last school
closed
in 1996. in 2015
canada's truth and reconciliation
commission concluded the country's
federal government committed cultural
genocide
through that system already there are
plans for marches across canada and
flags from coast to coast will be flown
at half-mast
many communities have announced that
they will not be going ahead with
planned events
for july the first even doug ford the
province of ontario's conservative
premier
seems to be siding with a down canada
day ford has asked the people of ontario
to reflect over canada day
on what has taken place however there
has been pushback from some canadians
namely ford's conservative brethren at
the federal level
as a growing number of communities
decide to skip celebrations
aaron o'toole the leader of the
conservative party of canada
has positioned himself and his party as
defenders of canada day
o'toole has gone as far as to question
if he's the only person running for
prime minister
who is proud of canada while politicians
do what they do
canadians are also split on the issue
according to a new legie poll
commissioned by post media
only 14 percent of canadians favored to
cancel the holiday
this year which marks canada's 1867
confederation
as an independent country that said only
say they intend to fly a canadian flag
on canada day for rt i'm alex milovich